my question is this um you know I'll use
this as an example and I'll get to the
question like for instance if you're a
member of Islam okay
do whatever you want I don't really care
but when you start committing acts of
terrorism and killing people now we have
a problem
you can be a Scientologist all you want
don't care give all your money to L Ron
Hubbard and the whole crew literally
don't care but when you start committing
acts of violence or hurting people on
the outside that's why I have a problem
so two parts are there any
um examples of them doing things outside
of the organization because I know
you're very
um implicit of what they've done inside
but what is the problem if somebody says
look I'm looking for meaning and purpose
in my life and I'm finding it here I
don't care what if they want to give all
their money to Scientology I literally
don't care that doesn't affect me so I
mean what percentage of the world is
Scientologist point zero zero zero one
percent so my question is this if you
want to practice Scientology and you
want to believe that L Ron Hubbard the
science fiction writer as the next
coming of Jesus
how about it buddy what's the problem
with that there is absolutely no problem
with that Adam you you can in this
country you can believe anything you
want and I firmly
firmly support that you can't do
anything you want and that's what you're
saying you can't believe in this and
then and say it's my belief that made me
go out and blow up a bus
Scientology
um let me break this down into two parts
because you have the internal part
scientologists to scientologists
what does it matter if uh Joe schmoe
goes and spends all his money and goes
bankrupt
um in Scientology
in in the microcosm it matters nothing
in the macro view this is an
organization that is doing this
systematically to people and is tax
exempt and your taxes and your taxes and
my taxes and everybody here who lives in
the United States who is paying taxes is
subsidizing those activities
the internal
abuses that go on to scientologists you
know I talk a lot about physical
violence that is being meted out to
people in the sea organization but also
the destruction of families is something
that that shouldn't be a part of
an organization that is being supported
by the government
then there is the question of outside
the realm of Scientology and
you know I give quite a lot of examples
of people in there who have been
harassed and had their lives turned
upside down because they did say
something negative about scientology I
go into some great detail about this guy
Bob Minton I sort of used that as a
microcosm of this is what Scientology
does based on the teachings of L Ron
Hubbard
Adam there is no other religion that I
am familiar with that has a department
that is their intelligence dirty tricks
department and has policies written by
the founder of the religion on how you
go about destroying someone's life
Scientology spends a lot of money hiring
private investigators hiring lawyers
creating smear sites creating videos to
smear people uh following them around
harassing their families
uh simply because they say things that
Scientology doesn't like
that too is subsidized by your tax
dollars
and that is wrong
and by the way if you go into that the
part that he's talking about where they
spend 25 million dollars to spy on one
man you know who spends 25 million
dollars to spy uh who is the one man
there's a number of these by the way he
he is the probably
uh I would be probably the most hated
man that left Scientology is my friend
here's what you what you need to um you
you may add somebody else on that list
but I would say it's probably you yeah
I would say we're like you know so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]